the excellent however not only cannot
escape the fate of being thus deprived
of life and spirit of being flayed and
then seeing its skin wrapped around a
lifeless knowledge and it's conceit
rather we recognize even in this faith
the power that the excellent exercises
over the hearts if not over the minds of
men
also the constructive unfolding into
universality and determinate nosov form
in which its perfection consists and
which alone makes it possible for this
universality to be used in a superficial
way
section 52 is very short just a few
lines but in it Hegel is sort of
bringing to a close some of the
reflections in the much longer section
that preceded it and he's talking here
about how it is that what's what's
getting translated as the excellent
before truffle iike that which stands
out what does he mean by that the
dialectical process the development of
spirit everything that's getting you
know further and further along in the
process and our understanding of that as
well there's a risk for this and we just
talked about that before even in the you
know famous Hegel triadic schema there's
a risk even in that of it becoming
purely schematic of becoming as he's
going to say superficial so what he says
is that the fate of the excellent in
this case and the excellent could be
whatever it is that we happen to be
devoting our attention to it could be
the holy it could be the beautiful
it could be reason you know intruding
into institutions through history it
could be the development of family
dynamics you know any of these sorts of
things can be deprived of life and
spirit he uses the German nth you know
constructions you know they're enticed
if they they literally are having
spirits stripped away from them or
distanced from them they're imagine that
they're being put here in our
consideration while the process is still
going on and the real stuff is happening
over there and we're looking at the
digested form there so they can be
deprived of life in spirit interestingly
and Hegel is noting something that's
that's very important here particularly
for the practice of philosophy it still
has power that whatever it is that we're
calling the excellent here still has
power over parts communitary he doesn't
say here insane he says good neuter
meaning sort of are effective centers
where we have our sentiments but not
over
mine's there's a lot of cases where
people will get into a philosophical
system and now they see the world that
way but their commitment to it is really
more emotional or a matter of their
desires a matter of their their
interests in the sense of you know they
are interested participants is
benefitting them in some way rather than
being called in by the older and starker
demands of truth which is what Hegel
would say you know Geist mind spirit is
sooner or later going to have to tackle
that's the force of the negative there
he finishes by by talking in this this
rather turgid sentence about how
developed unfolded universality can be
used in superficial ways he's calling
our attention to a risk that he's just
talked about earlier in a section before
that as being something like you know
turning Hegel's you know account of the
development of spirit through all these
different Gestalt and all these
different stages of consciousness into
something like all the jars now this is
not exactly the metaphor all the jars
full of different stuffs at the general
store or going into the hardware store
and you know pulling open all the
drawers and there's that kind of screw
there's that kind of screw it's
organized you can find a stuff when you
need it
you can use it to do some sort of
extrinsic project of your own but the
dynamism the connection the intrinsic
development has actually been lost and
so any use of it is going to be
superficial it's it's sort of taking
over what was you know one through very
difficult and laborious centuries old
decades-old work and culminating in the
synoptic view of it that Hegel has and
then turning it into greeting cards
turning it into memes turning it into
schemas that you can easily plop things
into that's what he wants to quash in us
against
the next section he's moving away from
that so this is kind of a culmination
and linchpin section
science dare only organize itself by the
life of the notion itself the
determinate nests which is taken from
the schema and externally it attached to
an existent thing is in science the self
moving soul of the realized content the
movement of a being that it immediately
is consists partly in becoming an other
than itself and thus becoming its own
imminent content partly in taking back
into itself this unfolding of its
content or this existence of it that is
in making itself into a moment and
simplifying itself into something
determinate in the former movement
negativity is the differentiating and
positive of existence in this return
into self it is the becoming of the
determinate simplicity it is in this way
that the content shows that it's
determinate 'no siz not received from
something else nor externally attached
to it but then it determines itself and
ranges itself as a moment having its own
place in the whole the understanding in
its pigeonholing process keeps the
necessity and notion of the content to
itself all that constitutes the
concreteness the actuality the living
movement of the reality which it
arranges or rather it does not keep this
to itself since it does not recognize it
for if it had this insight it would
surely give some sign of it it does not
even recognize the need for it else it
would drop its schema Tizen or at least
realize that it can never hope to learn
more in this fashion than one can learn
from a table of contents a table of
contents is all that it offers the
content itself it does not offer at all
even when the specific determinate 'no
say one like magnetism for example isn't
itself concrete or real the
understanding degrades it into something
lifeless merely predicating it of
another existent thing rather than
cognizant it as the imminent life of the
thing or cognizant it's native and
unique way of generating and expressing
itself
that thing the formal understanding
leaves it to others to add this
principal feature instead of entering
into the imminent content of the thing
it is forever surveying the whole and
standing above the particular existence
of which it is speaking that is it does
not see it at all scientific cognition
on the contrary demands surrender to the
life of the object or what amounts to
the same thing confronting and
expressing its inner necessity thus
absorbed in its object scientific
cognition forgets about that general
survey which is merely the reflection of
the cognitive process away from the
content and back into itself yeah
immersed in the material in advancing
with its movements scientific cognition
does come back to itself but not before
it's filling where content is taken back
into itself is simplified into a
determinate 'no sand has reduced itself
to one aspect of exhibit of its exact
own existence and passed over into its
higher truth through this process the
simple self surveying hole itself
emerges from the wealth in which its
reflection seemed to be lost
section 53 is a long and rather involved
section I've got a sort of schema up
here on the board hopefully it's not a
schematic schema cuz we're talking about
schematism in this right but it's
supposed to give you some way of
conceptualizing the various movements
and connections that Hegel's talking
about in here I don't have everything
that he says off on there because it
would be rather difficult to to
represent but one thing that we ought to
keep in mind when approaching this
section is that Hegel is talking about
two different things very explicitly
well really three different things one
of them is the contrast between
scientific cognition and the workings of
the understanding when Hegel is
criticizing the understanding she's not
saying that something like the conch in
understanding which has its own
categories that you know are sort of you
know posted on to or imposed upon the
phenomena so that we can make sense of
them that there's anything really wrong
with that
nor is it criticism Malaki and
understanding you know the understanding
was used by a lot of different
philosophers the intellect is another
way to translate it
what is criticizing is a static view of
the development of human knowledge that
doesn't take into account the sort of
reflexive position of the knower
involved in this so the fact that
categories of the understanding really
do in fact get generated through these
these processes it's not as if they're
all there and then boom when we put them
there because then we could in fact just
have a table of contents that we
transpose on to everything or grid work
so that's one point another thing that
he's really focusing on that's that's
what I've got over here is the nature of
real concrete determinants things how do
they get to be that way how do they move
from being
into alterity from self and then we
appropriate that back into themselves
Hegel thinks this is going on for
anything that's actually worth studying
so this is you know sort of a way to
capture to think through the dynamism
inherent in things that it gets lost
from the perspective of the
understanding the other thing is he's
trying to think about how should we
understand the larger whole science is
systemic and one of the things that's
attractive about the understanding is it
does appear to be presenting things in a
uniform systematic way the trouble is
that it flattens everything out and
places it into these boxes or schemas or
pigeon holes however you want to think
of it and doesn't really get to what's
actually going on in in the phenomenon
so all three of these are coming
together in this particular paragraph
there's another thing in the background
which is that we want to be thinking
about the status of the knowing or
thinking or acting subject the one who's
actually doing philosophy the one who's
actually adopting the scientific
perspective on things the one who has an
understanding but is going beyond the
mere schema thism of the understanding
the one who is trying to make sense of
the greater whole in which they
themselves are a moment and this can
also apply to the human being who is
doing the knowing of another being so
all that said that's quite a few
presuppositions to keep in mind so he
talks about let's start here says the
movement of a being that immediately is
and then immediately there is has been
sort of read into it the German is I and
so what that means is a being something
that actually exists something that is
something that can be run into or you
know experience in one way or another
and
the being of such a being the movement
the involved in such a being consists in
he says currently in becoming an other
than itself so we've seen this you know
and many points already to discuss
nothing is as simple as it appears in in
the past philosophers wanted to try to
boil everything down to the the simplest
stuff they might have a mode ISM where
they think it's something simple that
then becomes complex through
differentiation they may be pluralist
and that they think there's a whole
bunch of substances out there that are
ultimately simple and we can't say much
about them but maybe their qualities
need to think of lock is being along
those sorts of lines Hegel is saying
nothing is simple nothing that actually
matters is simple it's already got
within it this tendency to produce
something other than itself and Hegel
says this by doing this it becomes its
own imminent content so that means that
it for this being the other nests is a
way in which this being can come to in
whatever mode it has available for it to
do this get to know itself you know if
we want to take a human being I think
it's easier when we look at large-scale
sorts of things a human being thinks
they know who they are we have a sense
of self-identity right and then we
reflect upon ourselves and if we're
really being honest with ourselves we
come up with things that are incongruous
that don't actually fit into what we
started with and we say well that that's
not me but actually that is me and how
is that me and not me at the same time I
guess and his wife at the dawn line here
I guess it really is me and I wasn't
quite what I thought that I was you know
you can see something like this going on
in for example the famous discussion of
the faculties or parts of the soul in
republic book 4 where Plato is
Socrates lead these young men through a
discussion and says you know like as a
whole as a soul just one thing or does
it have you know different parts or
faculties or operations how do we know
that well you know we look for for
conflicts are there ever cases we know
that we desire things we desire a whole
bunch of different things so we have
appetites maybe they're all really the
same thing maybe this is one big kind of
desire or access appetite at the film
yeah who knows is there anything that
resists that is there anything that's in
this case other than that rationality
even if we were like pure straight-up
hedonists or people who said that really
it's all about desire there wouldn't it
still need to be some sort of reasoning
faculty or process that says yeah you
know let's do this desire but not that
desire because they conflict with each
other or it thinks out how can I get my
how can I have my cake and eat it to it
as the proverb goes that would already
be producing a kind of Altair be there
something new
something additional following out this
example so the soul starts out as being
something primarily desirous then it
also has something else that is also the
soul and then there's a process of
taking it back so that's been able to by
becoming more complex adopt a position
upon itself it can be reflexive now this
is partly taking back into itself this
unfolding of its content or this
existence of it that is making itself
into a moment this entire process here
is how a thing makes itself a moment
within larger holes within environments
within things where situations where
there's going to be another kind of
Altaria not just an alternative within
itself but the alterity on
other moments so he says in the former
movement that is in the becoming other
negativity is the differentiating and
positing of existence so again let's go
back to the Plato and soul example we
realize that there's something else
there and you know Hegel is not very
good at bringing this out right here but
we we grasp things oftentimes through
contrast we intensify the outlines of
something by having something else
that's not yet next to it and so that's
part of what's going on here the
original thing that gift gifts thing
started becomes more determinate stands
out more so does this other part that
actually turns out to be something
within it it's all part of one big
larger complex dynamism of its own and
so he says that's negativity and then
this returning to itself is the becoming
determinate simplicity the becoming of
determinacy how it becomes a determinate
concrete being by having this this
activity going on within itself this is
a metaphysical description of how things
actually are as opposed to the
appearance which says you know things
are just what they are you know this is
not a good example but this piece of
chalk is just a piece of chalk you know
III don't really want to do a galleon
analysis a piece of truck because I
think that's really boring but we can
say that about all sorts of other things
as well so he says it's in this way the
content shows that its determinant is
not received from anything else that's a
very important point a lot of people
want to say that that Hegel is all about
you know system and things only have
their meaning within the system as one
moment
in relation to other moments so they
don't really have any meaning or value
or you know persistence or agency of
their own here he's saying no there it
does matter how beings Zion de Zion them
actually encounter each other and engage
with each other and interact with each
other in terms of larger compositions
but as themselves they already have this
dynamic and this this you know
development of other nests of negativity
within themselves and the process of
taking it back there's already this this
process going on within them you know
outside of their relations with other
things the relations with other things
could enter into that they will do that
as we get into other parts of the
phenomenology but here you really wants
to stress this point so he says the
understanding and it's pigeonholing
process does something wrong
it keeps the necessity and the notion
the regress the concept to itself which
is what gives the thing determinacy
there's an internal necessity outside of
the thing unconnected at least at this
level to the other necessities that
could be governing or ruling or
arranging or ordering this whole he says
the understanding tries to keep the
necessity and notion of the content to
itself everything that constitutes the
concreteness the actuality the living
movement to the reality which it
arranges and again we have to keep in
mind that Hegel has a different notion
of necessity than what many other
philosophers are dealing with many
philosophers would say there there is no
necessity when it comes to things that
change or things that are not universals
oh you know when we get to the realm of
particulars there it's all contingency
causes do come
into play but there there's no internal
necessity that governs everything it's
only when we like you know abstract that
we could find necessity Hegel is saying
something very different he's willing to
say yeah there's there's that kind of
necessity that's that's true you know
not going to rule that out but there's
also a necessity that's involved within
the very life of a self moving thing
within the existence of something that
is actual and concrete quite a brilliant
thought there so he says the
understanding tries to keep this to
itself or rather it does not keep it to
itself why not because it doesn't
recognize it in the first place those
who are you who are relying on
philosophies of the understanding when
they encounter Hegelian dialectics they
will say well this just doesn't make any
sense you know he's he's saying all
these things that it just seems kind of
arbitrary
well that's because they've adopted this
point of view as the way things must be
and they never actually entered into the
Hegelian point of view and when it comes
to phenomena that Hegel wants to
investigate they don't actually look for
a necessity within the phenomena because
there's not going to be there anyway
because obviously it's you know so
particular and they don't grasp the
concept they don't grasp it as a self
developing entity so he says all that
can offer is a table of contents the
content it does not offer at all very
nice line there so then he says look it
will use an example like magnetism even
when the specific determinant is itself
concrete or real the understanding
degrades it into something lifeless
merely predicating it of another
existent thing rather than cognizing it
is the imminent life of the thing we're
cognizant it's made of an unique way of
generating and expressing itself another
so this is not really the best example
Hegel was actually not
best in dealing with purely physical
phenomena but let's go with him on this
anyway so we say this is magnetic or
Ayari operates according to two
magnetism aluminum doesn't write what
we're doing those were predicating you
know the understanding is really good at
doing this or thing X is y a is be a
falls into the class of things that are
B it's good at doing that and we have a
whole logic developed for dealing with
with you know that sort of stuff if
you've actually got some input you can
process it you can come up with some
conclusions that's all nice that's not
you know worthless there's lots of
activities lots of fields in which
that's really great stuff but it doesn't
get at what the thing actually is it's
made assumptions rather than and and
those assumptions the researchers who
carry that work out in the first place
they might have actually done this sort
of process of delving into the thing and
figuring out its guts and its workings
but then it gets put in textbook form
and then people talk about it and then
people manipulate it sort of like a a
counter like that famous you know blank
coin that's exchanged beyond the between
people without saying anything I think
that's from a mallarme poem I'm not
quite sure
maybe it's art all in any case he says
the formal understanding leaves it to
others to add this principle feature
that is of actually understanding it
instead of entering into the eminent
content of the thing which is this it
forever survey is the whole and stands
above the particular existence of which
it is speaking that is it does not see
it tingle says does not see it at all it
sees the particular only as particular
as opposed to the universal about which
we can actually have knowledge real
knowledge and Hegel say no real
knowledge also has to encompass the
workings of
real things and those are particular
sometimes those are individual so he
says what a scientific cognition do
instead demands surrender to the life of
the object this makes perfect sense if
you want to understand for example
here's an example from my own past when
I first got into a graduate school in
philosophy I was going to do philosophy
of language and the reason why I was
going to do philosophy of language is
because I had a real interest in in
foreign languages so you know French was
a semi foreign language to me because my
mother spoke French with me at home when
I was a kid but you know not awful lot
so I learned fresh learned a bit of
Mandarin never very much but you know
practice it with Chinese friends and
students learn German so I could you
know read stuff like Hegel by the time
that I was there I was already working
my way through Latin and soon to go into
Greek and I had an interest in in
languages as languages so I wanted to do
philosophy of language as a
philosophical examination of what the
hell's going on with this specific tall
language and I was shocked to find that
a lot of the people in the field didn't
actually know or Vince much interest in
foreign languages because you know they
well you know just gonna generalize
about about things so they read some
Vidkun style but we're not even gonna
read fiction Steinem German even though
it's available you can get facing page
copies just in case your your German
isn't good and you wanted to consult the
English and it really clicked for me
when I was reading fair non disel
serious course in general linguistics
I'm kind of funny we were doing a
reading group and I had the you know
fresh core and my friend had a very
poorly translated version and we only
have through like a couple pages because
he was saying so so service saying this
and that's
he's not saying that at all here's what
he's actually saying here's how I would
translate that but one of the things
that so sir said was well if you want to
be a linguist if you want to actually
study languages I think that you
probably ought to actually study
languages and not linguistics first
learn some languages so you actually
have some things to compare before
you're going to do the theoretical work
of trying to figure out you know the way
languages work you need to actually have
some exposure to the objects you need to
entered into as Hegel says surrender to
the life of the object I wouldn't want
to talk to a fish biologist who learned
everything merely by looking at text
books and studies I would want somebody
who's probably actually gone fishing
from time to time and who has been out
there on the lakes and perhaps even on
the oceans and handled fish in their
hands and and spent time being curious
about them and looking at them and
saying well this is a strange thing I
would want somebody who as most as they
possibly could would want to swim with
the fishes and it's that way for any
other phenomena that we want to study
one of the dangers that comes with this
is you know the attraction of the the
understanding approach is well it's very
objective but it's also detached from
the reality that it's supposed to be
investigating does this lapse into pure
subjectivism that's a that's a danger
but it's a danger that can come up
within the very system itself and be
handled by the system by saying well
let's actually think our way through
this
so he says absorb in its object
scientific cognition forgets about that
general survey does this over here which
is merely the reflection of the
cognitive process away from the content
and back into itself what's going on
with the understanding the understanding
approach is more about surveying the
human mind and the way that it's
organized
then turning to whatever the mind is
going to study and inserting that
content very you know counterproductive
approach in part because the human mind
is reflexive and because the human mind
also develops historically in connection
with other things so including other
minds right so it says scientific
cognition does come back to itself but
not before it's filling our content is
taken back into itself is simplifying
into a determinate Ness and is reduced
itself to one aspect of its own
existence and passed over and to its
higher truth so Hegel saying look you
need both sides of this you have to
surrender in a scientific cognition to
the object to the phenomenon to what it
is that you're going to be putative ly
knowing understanding interfering with
studying arranging ordering or else give
it up you're not actually dealing with
the thing itself if you're gonna be a
philosopher of emotion you better
actually experience some emotions and
spend some time watching other people
experience emotions before you start
your theorizing and you better spend as
much time as it requires in order for
you to grasp that content not just
enough time to finish a 15 week class or
pass a online test or something like
that or get a certificate then the
content tests you as to whether you
fully understood the content and then we
arrange the content into these larger
holes in which yes the content does
assume more of its meaning but part of
the source of its meaning is coming from
the very fact that it is something
existing which means that it is
something that self others there is the
process of negativity within it not
merely within us not merely within the
understanding but also within the the
phenomena themselves so we finish by him
saying through this process the simple
self surveying hole the self-serving
hole is a self
whole because human beings are part of
them human minds are part of that
emerges from the wealth in which its
reflection seemed to be lost so you know
you know in a winks are like a good news
bad news thing bad news is you got to
really work and you can't skip any steps
in understanding the process good news
is if you do that you can develop a
synoptic view of the phenomena and I
would go so I would go further and say
if you're training yourself in this sort
of approach to things it's transferable
Hegel didn't actually figure everything
out
he didn't survey every possible
phenomena his system has gaps holes
lacunae in it and we can use the Y
Elliott approach not schematically but
it's something that we have internalized
through our own practice this is the
same practice ground right here for
doing that this is the training wheels
this is the baby steps and a great book
job for being able to do that